[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAMZI RIZK: The four
of us that founded
the company are
photographers at heart.
And when we got
together in 2010,
the first thing we
did was actually
launch a photography
competition.
It was the world's first
mobile photography exhibition,
and we realized that we had
tapped into something that
is way bigger than
we had thought.
And it became clear
that there was
potential there to
build a company.
EyeEm is a community at heart.
It's a community
for photographers.
It's a way for you to take
photos, process them, share
them, and get a lot of feedback.
You can learn.
You can become a
better photographer.
It also has quite a wide array
of discovery functionality
that lets you sort of discover
places and people based
on the kind of photos that you
take and the kind of interests
that you have.
It's about the beauty
of photography.
It's about photography
in its purest form.
MATIAS CASTELLO: Design is a
big, big part of what we do.
And the photos are
not created by us.
So what we try to
build and design
is a canvas for any photo
to look at its best.
We made several changes
to make our app simpler,
to streamline the experience.
And that definitely plays
into our engagement metrics.
The most visible one
is probably the menu.
We removed several items
from the navigation
to make it clearer
what EyeEm is about.
Now you have access to the three
main parts of the app, which
are our Discover feed
to discover new content
and content that was
published around you;
your Friends feed,
which is where you find
all the photos of your friends
and the photographers you
follow; and Missions are photo
competitions where people post
photos around a certain topic,
and then win prizes, and get
published.
They access Friends and Discover
somewhere between 50% and 80%
more than before.
And Missions saw a more than
100% increase in access.
We also saw an increase
in people participating
in Missions because of the
way we restructured the data.
One of the other additions
we've made to the Android app
to make photographers'
life easier
was to improve the Camera button
and the interactions with it.
So you tap on the Camera button.
It pulls your most
recent images,
no matter where they come from.
And you also have the option
to use your camera or access
to the full gallery.
By keeping a single
action there,
we've seen a 73% increase in
people accessing our camera.
We've also seen increases across
the board of people editing
photos with EyeEm and
uploading photos, as well.
Designing for different screen
sizes and different resolutions
is not as hard as
people usually say.
The Android guidelines help you
navigate through the different
formats-- be it phones
or tablets, portrait
or landscape-- and
definitely act as a guide,
and help you adapt your
design and the feature
sets you have to
different screen sizes.
We think it's important
to follow Android design
guidelines, because that's
what people expect when
they're on the Android platform.
It's important to keep
those patterns in mind
and also to leverage
them, because that's
the easiest way for people
to know how your app is used.
RAMZI RIZK: What started as
a facelift became, basically,
us stripping down the app.
And what that led to is a much
more photo-centric experience,
a much more
streamlined experience,
a much faster experience.
We saw broad engagement,
and retention,
and usage across the board
on every single metric
that we have.
[MUSIC PLAYING]